Essentially a struggle problem — it’s
an open ended thoughtful, non-routine problem.
They’re given a situation.
We go outside and they pick a building.
They collect certain data, and using that
data as a group they have to figure out the
height of the building.
I may or may not give them a couple of hints.
So now Janet, go all the way up to the building,
to the very top.
Be super dramatic.
To like the end of my phone?
Double tap when she’s ready.
When you’re ready let us know and Brendan
will double tap.
Especially in math it’s so simple to just
be like, “This is how you do it.
Learn this now.”
You’re not going to remember that.
You’re never going to remember it.
How do we increase they’re actually coming
up with a solution to things?
How do they problem solve? 62.1 degrees.
Booyah.
We want them to be able to stand on their
own two feet and prove to somebody else whether
in school or in life why something is correct
or why something makes sense to them.